GOAL IN ALL FIVE GAMES THIS
SEASON.
BACKSTROM CLOSING IN.
FOUR ON THREE MAN ADVANTAGE.
GREEN THROUGH THE SEAM.
CHASED DOWN BY OVECHKIN.
TO BACKSTROM.
LURKING IN THE BACK POST.
BACKSTROM FOR WARD, AND HE
SCORES!
IT ALL STARTED WITH A BIG-TIME
FACE-OFF AGAINST THAT GUY'S
HOCKEY CLUB.
JOE WARD WINS IT CLEAN.
BECAUSE OF THAT THEY ESTABLISHED
THE SETUP.
LOOK AT THIS PASS.
LOOK AT DOWN LOW YOU HAVE BOYD
GORDON, YOU HAVE EVERYBODY
LOOKING AROUND.
>> Craig: BAD LINE CHANGE BY THE
OILERS.
LUCKY FOR THEM IT DIDN'T COST
THEM QUITE YET.
>> Joe: OVECHKIN GREETED BY
NUGENT-HOPKINS.
OVECHKIN WAITS AND FIRES ONE
WIDE!
LABARBERA VERY PUMPED.
CAPS HAVE IT AGAIN.
QUITE COST THEM QUITE YET, BUT
THEN IT DID.
THE TOP LINE FOR EAKINS ONCE
AGAIN VICTIMIZED.
MINUS TWO IN THIS GAME.
THE CAPITALS KEEP THE PRESSURE
ON.
GREAT PASS AND LOOK AT THE
PRESENCE IN FRONT OF THE NET.
THAT ONE DOESN'T HIT ANYBODY
OKLAHOMA CITY.
THE PRIMARY DEVELOPMENT TEAM OF
THESE EDMONTON OILERS.
BACKSTROM WITH COORDINATE.
BACKSTROM AND WARD CLICKED IN
THE FIRST POWER PLAY TALLY.
BANG-BANG, AND SCORES!
, ALL THE GUYS THAT NEEDED TO
SCORE HAVE SCORED TONIGHT FOR
THE CAPS.
HERE COMES THE CONFIDENCE AND
THE RED ON THEIR FEET HERE IN
WASHINGTON.
TICK TACK GOAL.
THERE YOU WILL SEE IT.